now to a major development that could
affect the direction of the war in
Ukraine we learned this morning that
Chinese president Xi Jinping will visit
Russia next week to meet with Vladimir
Putin in an apparent show of support
this comes on the heels of a mid-air
confrontation between a U.S surveillance
drone and Russian fighter jets over the
Black Sea video released by the U.S
military shows the moments before one of
the Jets clipped the Drone Tuesday
causing it to crashing is at the White
House region good morning
good morning Chinese officials say she
will be meeting with Putin from Monday
through Wednesday of next week it will
be their first meeting in six months and
comes after she secured his historic
third term as president this meeting in
Moscow also sends a strong message to
Washington as tensions between both
countries and the U.S remain high
Chinese president Xi Jinping and his
Russian counterpart Vladimir Putin last
met in September 2022 now just over a
year into Russia's invasion of Ukraine
the two world leaders are planning to
meet again Monday both countries made
the announcement Friday with the Kremlin
releasing a statement saying that two
leaders will discuss the development of
a partnership and will also sign
important bilateral documents this comes
on the heels of a report by Politico
that Chinese companies have been sending
assault rifles body armor and drone
parts to Russian entities the shipments
took place between June and December of
2022 according to customs data
unconfirmed by CBS news on the takeout
podcast White House spokesman John Kirby
told Major Garrett Thursday China should
think twice before providing lethal
weapons to Russia we don't believe that
it's in China's best interest to be on
that side of the war in in that way to
help Putin Slaughter innocent ukrainians
we don't believe it's in China's best
interest but obviously that they'll have
a they'll have a choice to make just
days ago a Russian fighter jet collided
with an unarmed American drone forcing
it to crash into the Black Sea video
released by U.S officials Thursday shows
the Russians making two passes from
behind the Drone dousing it in a cloudy
stream of jet fuel before clipping it to
demonstrate publicly
what type of actions the Russians had
taken we felt that it was important to
provide this imagery
CBS News has learned that those Russian
Pilots were acting on orders from
military leaders and in another
development this morning Slovakia
announced it will join Poland in sending
fighter jets to Ukraine in the coming
days making them the first NATO Nations
to do so the White House says that that
decision does not impact the U.S
assessment that Ukraine does not need
fighter jets right now and the U.S does
not plan to send any
waiter that's right something the
president said he was not ready to do
yet in an interview recently thank you
so much